hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to share with you the absolute
fastest way to lose weight okay I'm
going to show you a strategy that will
really work for you it's based on one
fat burning hormone called growth
hormone it's made by a little Glen in
your brain called a pituitary and it
works through the liver so growth
hormone is the main fat burning hormone
and one of the things that triggers
growth hormone is intermittent fasting
but I'm going to show you a strategy
that I been very very successful with
number one step one is you have three
meals per day okay you don't have snacks
you don't have five small meals a day
you have three meals a day okay no
snacks in between I'll get to what to
eat in a second but I just want to
explain the whole the template of what
you're going to do so for three days
you're going to have three meals a day
okay not no grazing at night just three
meals okay now after three days you're
going to go to two meals a day now you
might not be hungry in the morning you
might so if you're not hungry in the
morning have your first meal at lunch
okay then at dinner but nothing in
between
if you're hungry in the morning have
your first meal in the morning and then
maybe you eat in the late afternoon so
you just want to spread it out like some
people get hungry around 11:30 and then
they get hungry at 4:00 that would be a
good situation but just make sure it's
two meals a day and no snacks in between
okay why because the the snacking is
going to crease insulin and insulin is
going to lower the growth hormone so
we're trying to spike growth hormone
okay okay step three after three days of
two meals you're going to do one and a
half meals a day what does that mean it
means that you'll you'll do the first
meal okay and it has to be big enough
where you get the nutrients okay and
I'll explain that in a second but then
instead of having a second meal you're
just doing a shake a green shake and you
can do a green shake powder you can do
an actual maybe some kale and some
stevia berry flavored for your sweetness
but you would just want a green shake
okay now if it blow too you better
switch to maybe spinach or something
like that
but I like shakes like a little bit of
kale beet leaves and parsley and I put a
little bit of flavored liquid stevia
berry flavored and man it I can drink
that and I feel really refreshed so
that's like your half a meal right there
so it's really only one meal with some
nutria with a lot of greens because you
want to flesh out the fat that's being
burned
so now after three days of doing one and
a half miles you switch back to three
meals a day okay now for some people
that don't exercise very much and then
have a real stubborn metabolism they
might oscillate between two meals and
one and a half miles two meals one and a
half miles right through in here
some people need three meals so you can
depending on how you feel from this if
you're not too tired you can go to three
meals or just two meals so want to keep
rotating this what are we doing we're
basically eating and then we're not
eating or eating we're not eating back
and forth to induce a fat-burning effect
by spiking the growth hormone the key is
what you eat - okay so the first thing
you have is some vegetable why because
it's low carbohydrate it's a lot of
vitamins and nutrition nutrition you
need a lot of you need big salads or
vegetables okay I'm going to talk about
corn though okay so we got vegetable and
then some protein so the amount of
protein would be the size of a deck of a
card or the palm of your hand okay maybe
it's like five ounces that's average
sometimes a little bit lower sometimes a
little bit higher and then we do some
fat healthy fat why that's going to
allow you to go longer without getting
hungry so you want to start off with low
fats gradually increase it so we're
talking peanut butter you can do if you
do bacon make sure it's like non hormone
none nitrate bacon you can do coconut
fat so you can do a picado you can do
cook an oil you can make some keto bombs
I'll put some recipes down below there's
a lot of things you can do with that
olives nuts pecans but we need to fat in
there we don't want to do low fat
anything okay I don't go lean anything
so the key is no sugar no starches no
rice
no corn no potatoes no beings why
because it's too high in carb and no
snacks now this is just the fastest way
to lose weight and you will lose weight
and it'll be pretty healthy the key is
keeping your greens up to flush up the
fat that comes out so the point is we're
increasing growth hormone or rotating
this and until you hit your goal now
there's other things you can do to speed
it up even more like adding exercise but
this will least get you started so write
your comments below and I will see you
in the next video